All right.
Hello everybody.
Thank you so much for coming today.
My name is Brian Wiley,
timing people operations and one of the teams that I lead is the people
innovation lab where we happen to know that social sciences like the coolest
thing ever.
So it is my sincere pleasure to welcome Dolly Choate to Google.
You talk about a fantastic book that she just wrote called how good people fight
bias.
The person you mean to be?
Dolly is a social psychologist.
She's a professor of management at Nyu and she is writing about things that so
many of us at Google care desperately about and articulate the journey that I
feel like we as an organization are on today.
So it is such a pleasure to have him here too.
It's such an honor to be here.
Thank you so much to everybody for coming,
especially after a long weekend.
Well,
I have to start by confessing something.
Oh,
I have known to say,
uh,
after reviewing all of the unconscious bias literature,
helping to put together trainings and workshops and talking to Google is about
it.
At the end of all of this,
I often say social scientists have been great at demonstrating that we have a
problem.
Yes.
But they had been terrible at telling us how to fix it.
And I thought that was true until I read your book and you had done
such a wonderful job at piecing together a narrative across lots of different
studies and taking the results of those studies and translating them into
practical advice for those of us who want to be better.
So I appreciate that.
Yeah.
Thank you,
Brian.
I,
I think part of my motivation to write this book was that I'm as confused as
everyone else and trying to navigate the confusing space and trying to be as
good a person as I want to be.
And it occurred to me that there is some stuff and these dusty academic journals
that no one reads that could be helpful.
And my goal was a lot of the research isn't mine,
but I thought I could share,
rate it,
throw mine in,
add some fantastic stories and interviews.
And
you definitely did do that.
Thank you.
So I have so many questions.
Oh my gosh,
she had the chance to have lunch before and,
and for Dolly,
that's it.
She's like,
I need to go to the restaurant.
We didn't
just getting a rest for my questions.
Scott,
here's some that I thought our audience would like to hear the answers to.
And by the way,
we'll have a Q and a for about 40 minutes and then we will open up the mics to
your questions as well.
Um,
so at first I want to start with something that is so central to your book that
if you don't get this concept and agree with it,
it's like you shouldn't even read the rest of the book.
That's not a good sales pitch.
All that's a terrible sales transfer.
I believe we can all be there,
but I thought we had to start there.
And that is with the concept of bounded ethicality.
Ah,
yeah.
I'm going to quote something from your book.
Okay.
Founded ethicality is the psychology of goodish people.
Good Ish.
People are sometimes good and sometimes not,
sometimes intentionally and sometimes not like all of us.
This model of bounded ethicality challenges,
ways of thinking and talking in which you are either a good person or not are
racist or not and unethical human or not.
Yeah,
we argue that this binary notion is seductive but misleading and scientifically
inaccurate.
So this seems obvious when it's spelled out this way,
at least to me,
but what does it mean to internalize like founded ethicality for ourselves?
And why is it so hard to do so?
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Um,
so we've got a really tight corner that we put ourselves in when we think about
who we want to be.
Um,
research shows that on us one to seven scale,
most of us put the importance of thinking of ourselves as a good person above a
sex.
It's really important to ask that like mother Theresa,
good.
But just having an identity where we think of ourselves as the kind of person
that we would call a good person.
It doesn't your definition and your definition and your definition may be
different of what a good person is,
but whatever your own definition is,
that is something that most of us hold dear to us and we feel really threatened
when there's anything that suggests we're not hitting that good person bar some
minimum threshold of like being a good person.
Um,
I know I feel that way.
I got an email from a student,
uh,
telling me that I had assigned a sexist reading to class and it was a female
student and I'm,
I consider myself a feminist.
I have two daughters.
I am trying hard to raise them as feminists and to get an email like this feels
very threatening.
Like this is,
Oh my God,
you've totally threatened my good person bar.
Um,
my good person identity.
But the truth is when I reread the reading I was like,
Ooh,
it's a little like wow.
I,
what is the whole thing about like women just love to shop.
Like there,
there was some stuff in that article and it really should have caught my eye.
But I had,
I had my own blind spots and it just went right by me.
And the problem is if as a good person,
if I have to be in a super tight corner where there was no room for blind spots
and no room for mistakes,
I will not grow from that mistake.
I will dismiss that email from that student.
I will not learn from what she's helped me see.
I will keep assigning that reading cause I won't see the value in her critique.
And as a result,
my desire to be a good person is going to hold me back from being a better
person.
Our research on bounded at the quality and when I say our research,
I mean our field like,
like psychologists for the last 40 years have shown in so many different ways
that we do have blind spots,
that we do have lapses,
that we do make mistakes and the,
we do have unconscious bias.
We do or we are prone to conflicts of interest outside of our awareness.
And every one of those examples,
the question is for me,
are we just going to deny that or are we going to grow from it?
And so what I'm proposing is given that the research on bounded at the county's
clear,
let's break out of that corner that's super tight,
either or either I'm a good person or I'm not corner and give ourselves room to
grow.
And what that means is setting a higher standard.
Being a goodish person instead of a good person is someone who doesn't
necessarily make more mistakes,
but they do acknowledge more mistakes.
They do own more mix,
makes mistakes,
and they do learn from your mistakes than someone who simply is in that tight
good person corner.
Yeah.
When I read this,
uh,
that portion of your book,
it called to mind all the ways that we reinforced the binary in how we talk
about other people.
Like we'll talk about,
uh,
people as evil or that's,
this person is such a great person or this person's a criminal.
It's almost like we've created the boundaries already and then you exist within
it doesn't,
it doesn't lend itself to a growth mindset which you talk a lot about.
Exactly and that growth mindset is that work in progress mindset is everyone
here is familiar that where it's not either or good.
We are always getting better no matter where our starting point is and one of
the things that I learned the most from in writing the book was the people I
interviewed,
some of whom are like icons like Joe McNeil of the Greensboro Four 1960
Woolworths lunch counter sit ins like led the sit in movement.
Someone who's truly a civil rights giant.
Speaking candidly about his efforts to have a growth mindset about gay rights,
like a really moving story to me that says this either or binary is going to
hold us back.
We have to find the work in progress inside.
You use concepts in your books that were like seeing old friends to me because
they're concepts that are very important to us at Google and ones that we have
been doing our own research on it and have found to be internally important.
So growth mindset versus a fixed mindset,
which is this notion that um,
uh,
we all have things to learn.
Uh,
we can all grow,
we can get better.
We should be incorporating feedback is so important to how we tried to engage
with our work and with each other.
There's another concept of psychological safety and that is creating
environments where it's safe to express yourself,
to admit mistakes,
to learn.
Uh,
we have done our own research on teamwork and we found psychological safety is
the number one predictor of whether teams are successful in their endeavors.
How,
what I loved about your book is that you actually showed a pathway from growth
mindset to psychological safety,
to uh,
fighting bias.
Can you talk about those connections?
Sure.
And this is where I took the liberties that you can't take within science.
Where in science we would all been in a very narrow silo that Carol Dweck is a
psychologist,
her and her colleagues who've done the work on growth mindset.
Amy Edmondson is,
uh,
the organizational behavior scholar with psychological safety,
unconscious bias monitoring,
Banaji and,
and they're each doing really deep,
deep work in those areas along with their labs and colleagues.
But what that means is that connecting those doesn't happen within science.
Those things sit separately within our journals.
Um,
and so what I tried to do was step outside of the science a little bit.
I say in the beginning of the book,
like I'm going to step outside the science because I feel like we don't have
time to wait 50 years before somebody is going to actually run the studies that
connect all those things.
I think we can use our common sentence to see the connections,
growth mindset on an individual level.
Seeing yourself as a work in progress,
seeing someone,
seeing yourself as someone who can grow from mistakes rather than when you hit
an obstacle and make a mistake,
you shut down,
you cheat,
you quit.
That's what happens in a fixed mindset.
Well that's the psychological safety is the same concept in a team.
Do we shut down as a team?
Do we not talk about mistakes?
Do we not verbalize vulnerability or do we create a space where we can talk
about,
I think I messed that up.
I think I dropped the ball.
I'm really scared about what's coming next.
That's growth mindset to me on a team level.
And I think that then sets the stage for things.
Topics like unconscious bias.
Um,
it's tough to,
I think we've gotten to the point where we believe the science and unconscious
bias,
but it's still tough to believe that it might sometimes leak into our behavior
that we might sometimes enact harm.
Um,
and so that's where that psychological safety in a team where you can talk about
it,
growth mindset within the individual sets us up to do the work on unconscious
bias.
The thing that makes me sad,
it's about the way the public dialogue has moved on unconscious bias is that we
sometimes seem to be saying,
well,
because it's unconscious,
I'm no longer accountable.
Well that's like saying because I was drunk,
I'm not accountable for the harm I did when I was behind the wheel.
Absolutely.
It's,
you are still accountable.
The question is how are we going to take ownership and learn from it?
Especially when a scientist,
we have not cracked the code on how to de bias our brains yet.
So in the meantime we're going to have to use the growth mindset and
psychological safety as our tools.
That is definitely a theme I saw throughout the book,
which is noticing,
noticing,
noticing and being aware.
Exactly.
Being a first class noticer is a big part of it.
And then starting to think about if we can't de bias the brain,
how can we deep rise process the team,
the system,
the structures.
A story you were telling me
earlier,
just stuck with me about,
um,
being willing to not just notice,
but to acknowledge when we have,
when each of us has had a stereotype thought or expressed on unconscious bias
and we made it conscious and it had to do with your work with,
uh,
in prisons and people who are incarcerated.
Can you talk a little bit about what you're doing with prison population and how
you felt when you first went into that environment and how that affected you?
Yeah,
so I've had this really wonderful opportunity to get involved with the Nyu
prison education program.
And during the year I spent working on this book,
I had two priorities.
Uh,
I took a sabbatical to work with that prison education program and to write the
book.
And what that meant is I was teaching a four co for college credit course.
Really similar to the one I teach Mba students at stern on leadership management
and negotiation skills.
And I was going to do it in a prison in upstate New York.
And
what I realize now,
and I look back,
is that one of the traps I describe in the book that I was probably like writing
that chapter while I was actually displaying the behavior was I talk about the
savior trap,
about having this vision of yourself as being a do gooder,
who's going to save the day and have that feel good feeling that that warm glow
that comes from saving someone else.
And I,
I can now see how that was motivating me into wanting to do the teaching in
prison.
But the problem with the savior trap,
it said,
it's still kind of puts me like above,
right.
And otherwise is the people I'm engaging with.
And I saw that in the first couple of classes when I was teaching that I was
like super scared of my students.
And I definitely not view was not viewing them as individuals,
but within a couple of classes it was sort of weirdly normal to teach in a
prison.
Like they,
my students were just like,
and I know there's some alums in the room,
but they would just think,
you guys,
um,
they,
they were funny and they were quiet and they were serious and they were more
prepared and they were less prepared.
I mean,
they,
they had a whole range of personalities and they were just individuals who were
super motivated to learn.
Um,
now do I know that some of them did things,
uh,
that created real harm for people that led to them being in prison.
Some of them did.
There is all sorts of injustices in the system as well.
And is that confusing to me and does it create all sorts of like,
oh my God,
the long drives home from the prison.
We're like real confusing mental a times for me.
But what I realized by the third class was I had dehumanized my students.
I came in thinking I'm going to teach a group of felons,
I'm going to redeem them.
And that in of itself created this savior mentality where I was never going to
be useful to them because I wasn't seeing them as human beings.
And so it sort of clicked into place by class three that I had like a bunch of
just individuals that I was going to interact with.
And,
and one of them had read 106 books of the year before and showed me the list of
his books and the other one cried when we role played difficult conversations
because he was thinking about his son and they were people.
And now about three quarters of my students have been released from prison.
And when I encounter them and interact with them in the city and there in normal
clothes,
I truly realize that I had created this image,
this uniformed image of an imprisoned to person that was absent of any humanity
talking about prisons.
And the criminal justice system actually brings up another aspect of your book.
Now,
the first portion of your book is about,
uh,
taking social science and helping us understand how each of us can notice and
change our behaviors and to relate to people and have a growth mindset.
But there's another thread through your book,
which is about systems.
And so sometimes being,
uh,
the biases that we encounter are byproducts of systems that we've created.
And you talk about this in terms of headwinds and tailwinds.
I'm wondering,
can you tell,
tell me what,
what do those terms mean and is there any research that you can tell us,
uh,
about that demonstrates how that happens?
Sure,
absolutely.
So I stole the metaphor of headwinds and tailwinds from Debbie Irving and she
talks about forces like,
okay,
so imagine,
I'm like jogging so slowly that I do it really slow,
but,
okay.
But on,
if I'm jogging and I've got a good tailwind going,
I might improve my time from like,
it's usual 10 minute,
32nd mile to like a 10 minute,
15 second mile because I've got that tail and pushing me along.
But I don't get a sense that I'm got a tailwind.
You don't even feel tailwinds really,
right?
You just feel like you're kind of racking it that morning and you're just like,
I don't know.
It was maybe those,
those eggs I,
I'm just really like,
right.
But then when you turn or you'd make that run and then you do the u turn to come
back and now you've got the headwind and it,
you feel every bit of it and it does slow you down and your time shows it and
your fatigue shows in your motivation shows it,
that headwind is much more visible to us then the tailwind,
much more feelable to us.
And what a systems approach is about is what are the ways in which we create
very visible,
um,
uh,
headwinds and less visible tailwinds.
What are the ways those are built?
How we operate.
Um,
so I,
I,
when I sent this book proposal off to publishers,
I literally didn't have the word system in it.
I didn't have system or systemic anywhere in the proposal.
I thought this was going to be a book purely on the individual level about
unconscious bias.
And it was as I started talking to people and looking at the research that it
became clear to me that even if I somehow like one of the Nobel prize and was
the one who figured out how to divide this unconscious bias look like,
say that was my claim to fame,
right?
Wave the magic wand.
I still would not have solved the problem because our systems would still have
so much bias built in the way we were.
Um,
for example,
I used to work in professional services firms like investment banking and
consulting.
And when we would interview,
a big part of the way we would interview would be,
we would look for fit,
cultural fit.
Like,
oh,
is this the person we've the classic,
do you wanna um,
go on a long plane ride sitting next to them.
What'd you want to be sitting next to them on a flight to Asia cultural fit and
I was part of that system.
I interviewed people using those criteria,
but now when I look back and I understand better what see how systems work,
I realize I created a huge headwind for people who didn't go to the same alma
mater as me who didn't have the same hobbies as me because those were the kinds
of questions that like where the fit conversation could we banter about common
interests and in fact Lauren Rivera sociologists did an in depth ethnography
where she looked at hiring practices at elite firms and that's exactly what she
found was that what we call fit that's meant to capture performance aspects of
the job was in fact capturing things like passion,
hobbies,
and shared academic backgrounds,
things that weren't necessarily tied directly to the job.
That's an example of a headwind where were people from a whole bunch of schools
who could do the job,
who aren't going to get a chance at it.
There's people who have varied interests,
are very cultural backgrounds,
are very family backgrounds,
who weren't going to fit the mold of the kind of banter that we would do in
interviews.
And um,
and people like me benefit from that tailwind because I did go to those schools
and I do kind of have those hobbies.
I mean,
I can talk about marathon running,
I just don't say my time.
It was very interesting that you and your collaborator Katy Milkman Yeah.
Um,
took these notions and applied it to your own academic community,
which I think many universities
yeah.
Would like to believe that they are probably the most egalitarian,
uh,
institutions you can be a part of.
Um,
but she did a study that showed otherwise I,
Katy Milkman who's at Wharton and do back and Nola,
uh,
who's at Columbia business school is three of us went to Grad school together.
And it really common practice before you apply to a phd program is,
uh,
well I say really common,
really common if you're on the inside and someone tells you to do this.
So it's not so common is to email faculty.
At the PHD program you're interested in and signal that you're interested and
ask if they'd be willing to tell you about their research.
And you do all this before you send your application in.
So it's totally outside the official formal process.
And,
um,
all three of us as Grad students had been advised to do that by people in our
network.
And we did that and we did get into Grad school and we did get great mentors and
everything worked out happily ever after for us.
But we were wondering what happens to people who aren't as network disaster or
maybe people who do get this advice but,
um,
don't quite match the profile that unconsciously maybe faculty despite three
Galitary names might be looking for.
So we did something kind of sneaky,
sneaky.
It was a sting operation,
which as social scientists we call an audit study or a field experiment.
And you know,
I know like Google,
you're very familiar with field experiments.
So what we did was we created email addresses using people's names.
We pretested these names,
either be male or female sounding,
please forgive the gender binary.
Um,
and then white sounding,
black sounding,
Hispanic sounding Chinese sounding or Indian sounding.
So those were five racial,
ethnic identities to gender identities.
We cross them,
we have 10 identities now.
We created multiple names for each identity so we don't have any sort of
particular name effect for an identity.
And then we created an email address for every one of those fictional students.
We took the u s news and World report rankings of the top 260 schools for every
phd granting department in those schools.
We randomly pick the name of one professor.
And you remember it is as I'm in academia,
all our information is on the Internet were really easy to find slash stock and,
and so,
um,
so it was really easy to do this.
It was a lot of work,
but it was,
it was simple.
Um,
so now we've got our fictional students and we've got one professor from every
phd granting department.
And what we did was we said what every professor received one email from one of
those identities.
And our dependent variable was with the professor,
right back to a cold call,
email from a stranger saying they were interested in learning more about this
phd program.
There's a little more nuance I'm going to skip,
but if you're ever interested,
we've got some papers that get into the details.
But if I,
if I cut to the chase,
um,
we were comparing with the white male identity to all those,
not why male identities and,
uh,
the students.
And what we found was that if you were a white male student,
you were,
um,
you had about an 87% chance of getting a response to your email.
And if you were not a white male student,
you had a 62% chance of getting a response to your email.
And this is identical emails being sent in identical time with an identical
request.
And so even in our world of academia where we,
you know,
if anything,
we're stereotyped as being,
you know,
how we're stereotyped,
like being sort of bleeding heart liberals.
Um,
we were seeing what I have to assume was mostly unconscious bias.
It,
they're very well is probably some conscious in there as well.
But I think there was at least some unconscious bias at work.
Sobering.
Um,
I'd like to shift focus to work organizations.
Yes.
You happen to be sitting in one and ask you for some advice here.
Um,
uh,
you devote a portion of your writing to what happens within organizations and
for good reason because we spend much of our lives here and a lot of what we uh,
get,
uh,
money status Doroty comes to work.
So first of all,
I found your,
your definition of diversity and inclusion.
Very interesting.
So you define each of them differently.
Uh,
let's start with how you view diversity and how you view inclusion.
Yes,
thanks.
Um,
and these words are often bundled together.
Diversity,
inclusion,
Dni.
Sometimes we throw in a B for belonging,
right?
But the,
but they actually do mean different things.
And if we're really to measure success,
we're going to need to know what we mean.
Um,
the metaphor I've been using for diversity is I think of it is the gateway,
the,
the getting of the job,
the getting into the school,
the getting on the team,
the getting the promotion.
So it's,
it's a formal process.
It's got,
it's often got some legal um,
kind of guidance over what appropriate process is.
It is relatively easy to measure and it sets someone up to get through the entry
point.
The gateway inclusion I think of as the pathway and the pathway is what leads up
to that gateway and what comes after that gateway,
what comes before it comes after.
So this,
this study I just described,
the audit study is an example of a pathway study,
right?
It was not the formal application process and to the PHD program.
It was this informal.
If you were in the know,
you sent the email and kind of started this little banter with a professor.
Um,
that is very much a pathway process and pathway processes we don't measure,
they're hard to measure.
They can be as fluid as who interrupts who at a meeting,
who goes to drinks with,
who,
who gives eye contact to who,
who sits next to who.
These are the every day moments that can have a real influence on how people
experience an organization,
but we're not as equipped to measure them as we go.
And that falls into the inclusion side.
So if you think about inclusion this way,
there are hundreds of these moments that occur every single day,
right?
You devote a portion of your book on meetings,
which I found fascinating.
So if I work an eight hour day,
yes,
it feels like I spent 10 hours a day.
So that's I think the culture that we have here at Google,
but gave some tangible,
and
you're very optimistic.
I will say I have throughout your book,
which made it a pleasure to read.
Um,
uh,
but I think that the,
title of this section of your book was,
um,
meetings,
present opportunities.
That was great.
So,
um,
if you think about meetings is opportunities to be inclusive and to check your
unconscious bias,
what are the,
what are the tangible pieces of advice you would have for all of us who are
spending?
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Thank you.
Um,
for,
for letting me share that.
The uh,
the October fest conference room that we were in before you walked in here,
I noticed had an
run inclusive meetings placard up there,
which was fascinating and it mirrored some of the ideas in the book.
So Tony Prophet is the chief quality officer@salesforce.com and I interviewed
him for the book and you know,
when you have a title like chief quality officer,
I thought,
Oh okay,
let's find out what the chief quality officer recommends.
And I'm expecting some really like big plans and I'm sure Tony has big plans.
I'm not in any way suggesting he doesn't.
But what struck me is what his first answer was to my question of what do you
think is most important?
He said run better meetings and like run better meetings.
I mean everyone knows meeting suck.
Like what she's like sort of like part of organizational life.
Um,
and he said no,
he said your meetings mirror your organization,
whatever the headwinds and tailwinds are in your organization are happening in
your meetings,
but your meetings are a little easier to like,
you can get a grip on that.
You can start somewhere.
You can think about who should be in the room and who isn't in the room,
who should be,
you can think about are we balancing airtime?
I mean,
that's like a measurable thing you can think about.
Uh,
did we interrupt people or not?
You can think about,
uh,
did we create an environment in which people disagreed with each other or did we
have a meeting which I,
I use when I,
when I teach about meetings to my students,
um,
in our managerial skills class,
I call it the most precious real estate that we treat meetings like it was,
it's some little piece of desert land and a in a,
in an area that nobody wants that land,
that there's,
they're,
they're paying you to take that land.
That's how we treat meetings.
We just throw them together.
Not here.
I mean like other companies.
Um,
but but the truth is meetings are like fifth avenue real estate.
You getting multiple people in the room at the same time thinking about the same
thing.
That's fifth avenue real estate and that's how we should treat it.
That's the end.
You wouldn't just throw any old thing on fifth avenue,
right?
You would really put a lot of thought into designing it and that's in fact what
we do want to do in meetings is put that level of thought into it and if you're
going to put that level of thought into it and if you're going to use that level
of precious real estate,
what is the point of having a meeting where everyone agrees with each other?
Like did you actually need the meeting for everyone to agree with each other or
could you have just agreed to agree and not have the meeting?
So if you're not running a meeting where there's room for disagreement,
then the question is why did you have the meeting?
Some of the benefits of diversity and inclusion are a range of perspectives are
a range of opinions.
Is this a meeting where you can actually do that?
One of the dynamics that we know can happen in meetings is that,
uh,
people who you would not expect to have a legitimate point of view on any
particular topic are marginalized.
So you can have wonderful things being expressed that are simply not heard.
And,
uh,
in the Book You Talk About Your Dissertation Research,
which actually I demonstrated in a really profound way,
I thought with some like actual statistics behind it.
Can you tell us?
Yeah.
That was that research.
And what did you find?
Yeah,
that that takes us back.
Um,
so in my dissertation,
here's what I did.
I,
I asked people to like be in a game show,
but it wasn't really a game show.
It's just me and my laptop walking around south station in Boston asking
strangers to play this game with me.
There were different times you could do that.
Um,
so,
so the game I would ask him to play is I would say,
Hey,
I'm going to show you photographs and I want you to guess how many jelly beans
are in the jar,
how much this huge piece of machinery,
ways,
like questions that would be kind of hard to know the answer to without some
special knowledge.
And I'm going to pay you for how well you guess the closer you get,
the better you do.
But it's going to be like,
I forget which game show was the Hollywood squares.
It does this where you,
uh,
you first get to gas and then you get to listen to someone else's point of view
and then you get to revise your guests.
So the question is,
do you use the advice that someone else gives you or not?
And um,
the thing I vary,
the questions were the same for everybody,
but the thing I varied is whose advice they heard.
And they would just listen to it and little headphones.
And so the advice might be someone with a Hispanic accent,
it might be someone with a white sounding.
I realize those are not mutually exclusive but white sounding accent.
It might be someone who sounds African American,
male,
female,
like she had a bunch of different voices and um,
of course I rigged the whole thing so that all the advice was a hundred percent
correct.
Right?
So everybody heard the correct answers and it was just a matter of,
you know,
whether you trusted the advice from this unknown voice.
And what I found was I called it a stereotype tax that the people for example,
who had a female advisor in their ear or less likely to take that advice,
I think they made 669 cents on the dollar for people who had a male advisor
because they were so much less likely to take the advice of the female advisor.
And I,
you know,
I tried to standardize a whole bunch of things like the tone of the voice and
like everything that would sort of make something sound different other than
just the gender.
Um,
and so my dissertation,
the idea there was to show even in these really fluid moments like in meetings
for example,
when somebody throws an idea out and we have to make that split second of do we
keep going with it or do we,
you know,
move on those little quick moments.
We are potentially discounting
points of view and I know it can be difficult to counteract that.
If there were an easy solution,
we would implement it right now and have meetings would be amazing if you would
take a all points of view into account that were good points of view.
Um,
I had demonstrated problematic thinking right there.
Uh,
but it,
it,
uh,
in your book you are prescriptive about things that we can do.
One of the things that I noted was for if you walk into a setting and you have
ordinary privilege,
you are walking in with this stereotype that operates on your behalf and you are
a person with a growth mindset.
Someone who is on the journey,
uh,
to being a better person and you hear ideas using your ordinary privilege to
stand up for someone else's idea.
Was One way of amplifying any,
any other tangible advice,
advice to help us,
uh,
really hear good ideas.
Yeah.
I mean,
I also sometimes do the thought experiment in my head of,
of when I'm,
I can feel myself dismissing someone.
I imagine that the same idea coming out of someone else.
Like,
you know,
I'm not gonna say who,
but right now I'm picturing two colleagues in my mind,
in my,
in my work world.
And like if I take the idea out of one person's mouth and I put in another do,
would I be listening more carefully or what I be tuning out in the meeting right
now and,
and the truth is with the two people I have in mind,
I might be tuning out less if it was coming from someone else.
And so I think while it's hard to de bias the brain,
it isn't so hard to do the noticing to actually just kind of put yourself in
that counterfactual of what if,
um,
I'm gonna ask you another question,
but I will take audience questions in just a minute.
So if you have one,
there are two mics and please make your way up there and you can ask you a
question.
Um,
so uh,
what you've described in your book is a process that we can all go through and
many people are,
are engaged in that journey but many are not.
And based on some research that you had reviewed,
you sort of summed up three kinds of people that 2060 twenties,
you've got the easy twenties.
These are people who are intrinsically motivated to be unbiased,
they're really working and you know,
you can talk to them and you'll have a kindred spirit and then you've got sort
of this middle 60 who's really nowhere.
Like they're silent,
they're not really paying attention and these issues just have not surface for
them yet.
And then you've got this stuck 20 this is a 20% of people who are on really set
and entrenched in their ideas.
They are not willing to listen or to change.
And I think we all probably have some people like that in our lives.
The thing that struck me about that is your advice for this stock 20 is you can
choose to engage or not engage with them.
Um,
it's important to make your points of view known,
but don't expect necessarily that they're going to change along the way.
It's sort of a,
an agreement and that you come to with yourself and with them and workplace,
that's problematic because let's presume that a portion of those 20% are working
here with us.
Yeah.
We are in an organization that is trying very hard to have bias free systems and
processes to hold ourselves up to higher standards to make sure we all have
growth mindsets.
Um,
what advice do you have for organizations that have portions of these 20% in
there?
Um,
and we want them to thrive and add value,
but we also need them to be operating in a way that is living up to the cultural
standard.
We're trying to set it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So the 2060 20 rule can be applied to anything.
It's not specific to bias.
In fact,
I learned it from um,
organizational change consultant,
Susan and Nunzio who I used to work with.
Academia is a second career.
Uh,
consulting banking was first career and when I worked with her,
she would use this as an approach to any cultural change in an organization.
And,
um,
the,
the 2060,
20,
what it does is not say that we have to forget about the 20,
uh,
the stuck 20.
But it does say to be really careful of how you use your energy there because
that stuck 20 tends to be vocal and the middle 60 tends to be quiet.
And so what we can easily have happened is that all of our energy and focus goes
to the stuck 20.
And you find yourself in those arguments that nobody's listening to,
but you're doubling down and they're doubling down.
And the middle 60 is tuning out because this has gotten pretty boring.
Um,
and you've missed the opportunity to,
to either engage with the stuck 20.
You have a hidden audience in the middle 60.
So if you're getting engaged here,
at least know the middle 60 is listening or could be listening if you could be
engaging.
So rather than it being a,
you're trying to convince this person,
think of it as I'm trying to actually shape a larger groups perspective.
And in doing that you are going to shift norms,
right?
So when you move the middle 60,
which could go this way or could go this way,
you're shaping the norms and those norms are going to do the work on your stock.
20 norms are incredibly power,
powerful shapers of behavior.
And so you may not be able to convince the stock 20 but you are able to shape
norms and influence the views of people around you.
And that will do the work.
That's a powerful lever.
I found it,
uh,
amazing to,
to read about how you interact over social media with people who have contrarian
points of view and you write that you will engage with them knowing that the 60%
right,
you're reading.
So you're really engaging them for the 60% and not with any expectation of
changing the person.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I don't,
I don't,
I know when I'm not going to get anywhere in one of those social media things
that we all find ourselves in.
Um,
but what I do do is speak to the lurkers cause I know,
cause I learned too,
I know there's a whole bunch of people lurking and like waiting for the fight to
begin and instead of like going into the fight,
now that I've got their attention,
I just use it as an opportunity to speak.
And sometimes I literally just speak past the person arguing with me.
Like,
I mean I'm respectful,
I'm always respectful,
but I don't even worry about like getting into what they're saying.
I just say what I wish the middle 60 new and use it as that,
that moment.
Now that I've got this sort of the fight,
uh,
their attention on the fight.
Yeah.
There was a powerful moment,
uh,
in your interview with Joe McNeil.
Yeah.
And you had asked him whether in hindsight he would have done anything
differently when you were sitting at that counter at Woolworth's.
Yeah,
exactly.
Joe McNeil,
Greensboro for who we talked about earlier.
He said,
first I asked him,
would you have done anything differently?
Looking back?
He's in his mid seventies now and me first.
He's like,
no,
I think,
I think we did it right.
You know,
and then he kind of took a sip of his coffee and he said,
you know,
you know what I would've done,
I would've spoken more to the people who were silent.
Basically he was saying the middle 60,
I would have given them a chance to be a better person too.
That's what I would've done.
And I just thought that was such a powerful insight from somebody who was really
on the front lines,
risking everything has life,
everything.
Um,
any questions from any of you?
All right,
I've got more.
Good.
Huh.
So I,
the growth mindset that you described in the book,
uh,
will lead us to ask a lot more questions than we're probably asking today.
Um,
it will lead us to take seriously the things that people tell us that we may
have dismissed.
Our old self may have dismissed,
but the new self is actually reflecting on it,
see if there's some truth to it.
Um,
in the process of having this growth mindset and being on this journey,
you're asking the people who may be most disadvantaged,
most marginalized,
um,
the ones who are the negative recipients of the unconscious bias and do a lot of
educating and engaging.
Right?
Is that fair?
I don't want to put that burden of education.
Um,
so this is where those of us who have ordinary privilege,
ordinary pillages a piece of your identity,
you think least about we all have multiple facets or identity.
Um,
street.
I can go weeks and months without thinking amount of fact that I'm straight.
It's the whole,
the world is set up for me,
right?
Someone asked what I did this weekend,
it's easy to just share my,
my husband and I did this or whatever.
I can put pictures of my family and I don't worry about being a panelized in
some conscious or unconscious wait.
Work ordinary pillar does a piece of your identity you think least about cause
that's where you have the tailwinds.
And that's also where you have surprising influence.
And so studies show that let's say a black person says something about a racist
joke versus a white person saying something about the same racist joke.
The black person is perceived as being whiny,
whereas the white person will have more influence and make spec.
They're going to have in that moment and there's been multiple studies that have
basically shown that same pattern that in the piece of your identity where you
have ordinary privilege,
you also,
what ordinary privilege brings is unexpected influence.
And so this is where we were.
So many of us feel helpless right now.
We actually have a reason to be optimistic that we have more influence than we
realize not to speak over or for someone else,
but to take some ownership so that the same people aren't doing the same work.
Educating others time and time again.
The other thing I really liked is I interviewed Subha Barry,
who's held a number of senior roles in financial services and is now I think the
president of working mother media and she's kind of been fighting a bunch of
fights for decades,
trying to create more equity and equality in organizations.
And I asked her how she sustains herself in that.
And She described flipping channels on the TV once and running across this
national geographic special about birds.
And it was all about the v formation that some birds fly in.
Do you ever notice that?
And what she didn't know,
and I didn't know until she told me,
is that when you see that v formation in the sky and it looks like it's just
static,
the same birds that what's actually happening as the lead rotates to the back,
that there's this constant rotation.
And that's because the lead bird is the one who's taking the headwinds right
time.
That's the hardest job to break the wind up front.
And so most exhausting.
So the way the birds are able to sustain this is by not always having the same
lead bird.
And I think that's another piece of this is when in the areas in which we have
ordinary privilege,
how can we step into that lead bird role?
Again,
not speaking over four people,
but taking some ownership for trying to create the kind of environment,
culture,
workplace that we value.
Oh,
hi,
professor.
Hey,
um,
so in your amazing class at Stern,
you taught us that there were a lot of different types of cultures that could be
successful.
Um,
but building off the conversation about bias in hiring practices,
how do you,
um,
have a hiring practice that gets the right person for culture without sort of
culture fit being synonymous for some sort of implicit bias in that?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So we think it's a matter of thinking about where,
um,
what it is about that cultural fit that's going to enhance performance and
actually getting into what the behavioral indicators are.
So if,
if what's needed is it,
we need to be able to spend long periods of time together without driving each
other crazy.
We can do that without necessarily having to have gone to the same cluster of
colleges.
It's more a matter of maybe what you do and your um,
your interviewing or hiring process is you actually screen for what is it like
to spend time with this person or how do they react under stress as opposed to
relying on the more informal banter that makes assumptions that just because we
went to the same schools we would have the same comfort level and,
and I realize it's not that explicit,
you know,
the processes.
I was part of an advanced,
we were never that explicit that that's what we were,
we were looking for the same schools,
but those sort of what we ended up doing.
Thank you.
Nice to see you.
Hey.
Hi.
Thanks for coming here and having this conversation.
Thank you for having me.
I was wondering what your advice is for like when you make a mistake,
particularly in the workplace,
like how,
how do you recover from that?
How do you make sure you've
repaired the harm that you've done and and like how does that work?
Absolutely.
So I think it's like an all other parts of our life when we have some sort of
pho par or error that creates negative impact on others.
The ways in which we know taking accountability works here too.
So,
um,
you know,
we'll use an example.
It's not,
I'm sorry you were offended by that,
right?
It's,
I'm sorry that I did harm.
I'm sorry for my error in judgment.
I'm sorry for my ignorance.
And then where you can go with that is you can ask if the person is interested
in educating you about the harm you've done,
but you don't expect them to do it because that is putting labor on the other
person to then go through,
not only have this harm been done,
now it's my job to educate you about your blind spots and deal with all your
emotional reactions and not offending you and all that sort of stuff.
So I think it's first the apology,
or is it you can make an invitation if the person's into it,
great.
If they're not,
it's your job to go figure out how to educate yourself.
Thank you.
Uh,
in your book,
you read a bit about,
um,
uh,
events that traumatic events that have been happening in the United States,
whether it's the shooting in Orlando at a gay nightclub or um,
uh,
the police shootings that have happened.
And we know people who are members of the communities that would have been
affected and your profile a different people and how they've processed that or
how they've provided support on what is a lesson that you learn from them and
you would pass on to us.
Oh my gosh.
So psychologists call this hidden grief that at any given moment,
pleading now one out of four of us is sitting here in this room with real hidden
grief,
whether it's the loss of a loved one,
whether it's a traumatic event in your life,
whether it's something happening in the news that feels very personal to you,
that there is something,
there's a lot of work you're doing just to hold it together at any given moment.
And in what I read about and learned about with hidden grief and thinking about
it in the context of national events and international events and how they
affect,
for example,
my students.
So,
you know,
I teach at Nyu,
I deal with students,
um,
on,
not on a daily basis,
but like on,
on a flowing basis where I see them over the,
the,
um,
stretch of an entire semester and things happen in the world during that time.
And it used to be that I kind of just,
I didn't know what to say.
I'd say nothing and I have to confess it,
there's still a portion of times when that's exactly what happens.
But I think what I learned from the hidden grief research was just the noticing
that someone's grief is there and the acknowledging that you see it,
the bearing witness of it,
not inserting myself,
not making myself the savior,
not cookie seeking,
meaning a cookie seeking is like looking for their validation and how awesome it
was that I checked in on them.
Um,
but just saying,
hey,
how are you holding up?
And that's actually a phrase that I learned from one of my former students.
The how are you holding up?
It allows the other person to go in any number of directions.
They can say,
Oh my God,
I'm falling apart.
I need to tell you everything.
Or they can be like,
oh,
you know,
good,
everything's great.
You know,
like they can use that question to go as deep or as lightly as they want,
but they know that they're seen.
And so I think,
um,
they didn't,
grief piece is one of the places where I'm trying to do the most work of
figuring out how to not allow silence to look like indifference to others.
And that is how it's often perceived in the workplace.
Hi.
Hi there.
First of all,
I wanted to say,
Brian,
thank you so much.
You ran the I'm biasing video.
I'm a noogler so I saw an hour and a half of them by a sane training and now I'm
having a little Google crush.
You're doing a great job.
Thank you for putting together these programs.
Um,
I'm definitely brush at 20 slash 20% here in part because I want to be a better
person and I want to be a better coworker.
Um,
and I'm a sociologist,
so I'm constantly thinking about the group and the systematic biases.
And I think being at Google has really challenged me to see where I fit at the
individual level and really like what's going on there.
And you said,
ah,
you know,
changing the unconscious biases in our brain is really hard.
Um,
and then you kind of move on and I want to open that up a little bit.
What is it that I could do or anybody could do to really push ourselves to find
the blind spots?
Because naturally our brain doesn't want to find them.
Um,
how do we push ourselves to become more comfortable with these truths that maybe
we didn't want to acknowledge before?
What,
you know,
are there exercises or they're great podcasts?
I mean,
where would we start to unpack?
Well,
that might be,
I don't know.
You only thought Sarah would be.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Thank you.
Um,
so you may have already done this,
but I'll just throw out ideas for Fairview.
So there's the implicit association test,
which is called the IAT.
It would,
they have done that through the training.
Okay.
So implicit.harvard.edu is the site where you can find it.
You can do it completely anonymously.
It's about a 10 minute test on the Internet.
It is not a perfect test.
It is.
It is,
uh,
an in progress scientific method that we are trying to improve.
We meaning we the field.
Um,
but it will give you a sense of where your blind spots are.
You can pick different topics.
There's at least 20 tests up there,
race,
gender,
skin tone,
physical ability.
It goes on and on.
Sexual orientation,
religion.
Um,
so that's one place to start.
The second thing you can do,
there's a great story in the book about Rick Clough who some of you may know at
Google ventures,
um,
who I met at the same conference.
I met you at Brian at the rework conference a few years ago,
uh,
ago when you wrote in the book that there was that moment of awkwardness or
trying to get your taxi back.
It made me feel bad.
It made you feel bad.
I was like,
Dolly,
I'm so glad you didn't get your attack saying like they had the open dinner for
the conference and you know,
when you arrive at something and like there's going to be that networking thing
and you get there and like for,
there's that where you have nobody to talk to and you're just standing there and
I just like want it to run and get my taxi back.
Um,
and I could still see it like sort of out of the corner of my eye.
And then Rick Clough has saved the day and said,
hi,
I'm Greg.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so I ended up having what we would have been a small talky conversation at the
entrance of what was a fantastic conference in every way,
um,
with Rick Clough.
And when did things he talked about was after he took the IAT,
he got a gender result that he wasn't happy with and didn't match his perception
of some self.
Um,
as I'm putting this in quotes because he cringes every time I say it,
but like as one of the good guys,
meaning someone who hires women,
promotes women,
um,
creates opportunities for underrepresented groups.
He really saw himself as the current person who didn't need the unconscious bias
training,
who didn't need to take the IAT.
And then when he got the result,
he was taken aback and he thought,
well,
Huh.
I don't know.
I don't think that's true.
And so we decided to start,
he's very active on social media and I think in his particular role at Google
ventures,
social media is a really important part of the platform and influence he has.
So he's like,
I don't know what they're talking about.
And he starts going through and like running some algorithms on who he follows
on Linkedin,
on Twitter,
who he retweets,
who is connected with things like that.
And he kept getting that he was,
uh,
his,
his network was 80% male and this was not what he expected at all.
And it was consistent across all the platforms.
Then he started noticing on his calendar that he had been sitting on all male
panels.
Again,
an important place where his voice and platform have influence.
And so he realized through this little self audit he did.
And so that would be the second thing I would suggest is a self audit.
In his case,
he felt like these net,
this network was an important place for you.
It might be.
Who are the last 10 people you had coffee chats with to network about Pete?
I'm sure you all have friends who want to work at Google.
You know,
who are the people that you're having those informal conversations with?
If you're a big movie person or,
or,
um,
both person.
What are the last 10 books or movies you consumed?
How different were the voices and experiences and those books and movies from
your own versus how similar were they to each other?
Um,
what associations are you?
We're not just dealing with our implicit associations that we've built over our
lives until now.
We're creating new ones right now.
Which ones are you creating right now?
Those are things we can actively change.
You can change who's in your network,
you can change what you're consuming,
what you're feeding your brain with.
Um,
I think that's like,
those are immediate steps we can take where we don't have to do the,
the bigger work of systemic change.
Thank you for your question.
All right,
we're coming at the end of time.
Uh,
Dolly,
thank you so much for spending time with us today.
Uh,
as,
um,
our noogler mentioned,
we have an unconscious bias curriculum.
All new hires are invited to watch this video to learn about it.
And uh,
we'll get emails every single week after the video goes out in the most common
email is I want to learn more and I want to know what I can do.
And from this point forward,
I'm going to say,
read your book because there a lot of practical advice there.
So thank you for [inaudible].
Thank you so much.